hello hi there and welcome to the lobby
games what's weekly hang out every
Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific right here on the
gamespot com no it's just gamespot com
if you type that into probably won't
come up with a Jeff you know the
gamespot.com goes somewhere entirely
don't you think yeah yeah I registered
it years ago nice I pointed it some good
stuff so you might want to check that
out who's actually hold off for a little
while dokes we got an hour's a show to
talk about video games and peter brands
here hi how you doing little sleepy but
don't worry I'll be good as long as
you're awake by the time we're going to
gamescom in a couple of weeks it'll
it'll all be good yeah it seems like
that's when the rest of the video game
news is gonna happen is like nothing
going on gasps ended a lot of people
over there or two of us from the US and
UK team oh right yeah UK team yeah cuz
Sony's pulled a so yeah Shoney's on
having stuff there the Paris thing on
right like Microsoft's gonna have the
games that they said they were gonna
have yeah except scale band and right
back to back down dan and quantum break
him but like yeah I don't know like I
feel like I've gotten some invites like
hey you're coming to games come and it's
like every single time like even if we
were going i wouldn't go crazy watching
me so there's usually a whole whole full
of free to play MMOs there that's
probably gotten smaller over the years
but waiting for the farm simulator MMO
there they're showing it thickets me you
think it biggity three at the german
thing it's just like an attractor there
that's like a people american for money
just an overall is going well tarnation
i'm farming up a storm and it's teed it
up i really want to go I've never been
I've never been to Germany at all so I
really would like curse Simmons never
been to Germany oh yeah but uh yeah it
just it never makes sense to go yeah
yeah I guess under the properties will
be less and less sense it seems to its
relevancy kind of it got real big there
for a while it seems like it might be
scaling myth right well like Europe
needs something right yeah there was
never a big show in the UK yeah girl
gamer expo right yeah so I guess it
feels raised red res res that's that's
that's where it's all every year you
think this is gonna be the year they
announced a res sequel at res what are
we doing with our lives
as for old games res might be one that
turns up on Xbox one's backwards
compatibility list even good way no I
guess it did release that yeah sure
resin yeah why wouldn't it so the xbox
one preview program yeah you could sort
of opt into it it's kind of difficult to
get into I tried it last week sort of
like opposite people invite you and then
it's kind of like up to them whether
they send you an invite or not I think
it's that you you get flagged but then
you don't get pushed the latest firmware
until they push it at a new one out to
everyone all right okay so it might be
that you get in right before they've or
right after they put one out and I'll
take a while for you to catch up or
something like that but generally yeah
are you on it right now yeah I've been
on it for like a years I like whoever
sent you know it's been been going on
for a long time and yeah it's you just
get more frequent firmware updates so
you find yourself cut like saying like
Xbox on and nothing happens you're like
oh it must've been another damn firmware
update right they've got supporting out
for like over-the-air HD tv tuners okay
it's interesting that's not on the
regular xbox but that's like a pretty
neat feature hmm but I don't know when
that's actually [ __ ] is it is it not
live to everyone yet I thought what yeah
I don't know it's old I got a box as
well didn't it so they don't need that
was live in the UK before other
territories where that was like a bigger
deal and now it's finally in the US but
yeah they they saw that thing for 80
bucks or 60 bucks or whatever it is and
I do already I thought so I don't know
when I money language I wasn't sure if I
was like commercial yeah no no that was
preview program stuff right yeah I don't
know brad has one and yeah but Brock I
was like freaking robots to like walk
around with his face yeah that's let's
not get into that and but you you're on
it there's a bunch of games now
available that was compatibility like
stuff that was on the 360 so does like
meet boys on its mass effects on us yeah
geometry wars oh cool one of the few 360
games you would still want to play yeah
as available um and yeah but actually
both of you pinatas our partner that
part of the preview or is that yeah in
there and soak a banjo kazooie zinta got
a rare stuffed presumably that rare pack
they're bringing out rare replay yeah
well if you think about it like the the
thing that there's business involved
with selling these things or putting
these things up on xbox one its mobile
business so
sense for a lot of the stuff to be kind
of Microsoft and stuff where developers
don't necessarily have a reason to say
no yeah and mass effect might be a good
idea to like you know get all those xbox
one fans interested in possibly on drama
die when it comes out in a couple of
years yeah maybe I know that seemed like
that's the one that is now I mean it's
still in preview like they're saying
it's gonna be one to one and like online
compatible with existing with real xbox
360 hardware but it sounds like right
now stuff like mass effect isn't running
quite as well and well in some cases
runs better I don't know view that all
we did like a video comparison we sort
of saw some screen tearing there in the
the xbox 360 version they've like
lowered the frame rate but implemented
vsync it seems like to get rid of that
so it's maybe not better graphics but a
better experience sure I guess I'm one
of the games will get into what we sort
of want from that program in a bit but
one of the games that I know you want
that has just been an answer will be
coming out to it is at burnet paradise
yeah so so was there an update because I
know there was a criterion got out there
and said like we're talking to Microsoft
more news soon okay is that it no yeah
that's it okay so presumably so you know
we talked to Microsoft a couple of times
during e3 about this stuff and they've
made it pretty clear that it's a
business thing like they're emulating
the 360 on the Xbox one period like full
compatibility know you know they like no
shim that has to sit between the game
and the hardware that's like game
specific stuff which you know for a lot
of pc based emulators there's a lot of
really crazy game specific hacks that go
on on some of the more advanced systems
like they're kind of saying that this
isn't that that this is going to work
across the board and it really is just a
matter of a publisher or rights right
we're saying yes yeah so the idea that
criterion is talking to Microsoft about
it like no criterion would talk to the
rest of EA or something and say like
just say yes yeah like that's that's how
Microsoft pitched it so I'm not really
sure what that means except that maybe
since it's still a preview program thing
like they're just not done emulating
that yeah so maybe there's some
conversation to be had there it's weird
with a game like that because paradise
is like an online enabled game so
presumably they need to keep all those
servers open yeah yeah there will be
like Xbox Live compatibility you're even
going to have the xbox 360 dashboard
when you hit the home button in the xbox
one controller it like straight up beeps
at 36 a can you hit back and started
back in Star
sure yeah oh really and that the guide
pops up yeah well yeah and the size for
games that haven't been announced yet
Microsoft have actually put up like a
website you can vote on for like your
favorite wish list of games yeah and it
makes for interesting reading I took the
top tragic 30 tragic maybe yeah and the
top one up there at the moment is a
black ops 2 followed by red dead
redemption or I'll support that that's a
good shed at Skyrim I got ya I got a
surprise that there was no Skyrim xbox
one ps4 announced already right like HD
rehab and maybe maybe there will because
it's honest yeah modern warfare 2 halo
reach black ops gears 3 fallout 3 cod
for mass effect 3 modern warfare 3 he's
in a new new vegas i think called duty
world at war left 4 dead 2 gears of war
two so mostly shooters six of the top 13
are call of duty games that's resilient
it's not so depressing like to the idea
that like there's this annualized
franchise that like people i get one or
some of that speaks to like the the way
call of duty's fallen off for the past
few years and then but you know like
people want black ops 2 that's kind of
the high-water mark yeah the idea that
like people were like man they need to
bring back modern warfare really yeah no
world also they won't yeah right like
it's the the big thing Microsoft did by
kind of getting out there and saying
that it's it's like up to the publishers
is like disavow all responsibility and
go hey it's on them it's a business
thing it's on them so whenever you
complain about like hey I'd really like
to play my old call of duty games like
you complain to Activision not Microsoft
yeah and it's like smart in a weird way
but like I if I were Activision I would
never flag any of my games for backwards
compatibility cuz why would they just
they don't make money off the youth
sales of those games they could put them
up you know there they are up for
digital download like you could but like
you're not there's no additional money
coming in to do that yeah they're trying
to push people to the next call you
could be countable izing your own Marcus
yesica Lee yeah they'd be better off you
know like you you know they'd be more
likely to say like hey we're putting out
call of duty classic it's all these
multiplayer
yep in one big downloadable thing buy it
all over again I feel like the one
exception is like arcade games and
downloadable titles so they can still
monetize that so I can totally see the
incentive there and that's again the
same thing they have to negotiate that
with the license holder right that's
weird with something like they say super
meat boy which is actually getting like
a ps4 release I played it at e3 but the
ird own it on 360 so I've like zero
impetus to like to buy it on xbox one
now right well why don't we I exactly
why would you though then and they
that's a case where like the work is
done so why would they put out an xbox
one version of Super Meat Boy if they
could just make the 360 version
available for sale to xbox one owners
and that's something like they you know
they need to overhaul their store their
overhauling the entire interface as well
later this year so you know it's not a
1080 60 chef come on but it's isn't it
though it's just a scalar it's just a
scalar speaking of games than that
haven't been announced yet Peter I asked
you to think of a couple maybe you'd
like to see on the system yeah coming
over to the Xbox one I don't have an
xbox one all right but if I did I would
do you know stake in the driver no no
but like I really like fighting games I
love Street Fighter an Xbox one is not
getting street fighter 5 ever in oma
shape or form ps4 just got ultra street
fighter 4 ported to it there's no xbox
one version and they were talking about
it when they announced it about seed
like last August but it's not there so
ultra street fighter 4 i think is the
one game that i would really say like
really deserves to sort of be in that
backwards compatibility this because
there is no street fighter right now on
xbox one and that may be the only
solution in the near future yeah yeah
that's a good call for sure I was
wondering if say happy action theatre
would make its way over with the Kinect
stuff like will those connect be lower
no really yeah man that work was too
hard okay ya can't slating that stuff
yeah exactly jeffers anyone's a stick I
to you bottom or an ax 0 I you go
through this site like all the the user
vote stuff this you as a user voice
right let's say they use it for a lot of
feedback mechanisms not just this and
the you start to dig deeper and deeper
yeah that list where it's like they're
like 47 people that said yeah Bomberman
a tour de france 2011 yeah i think i
think it should be everything I mean you
know
it's there there aren't really a ton of
games that I necessarily need to go back
to the exception of burnout paradise mmm
which by the way was on the fifth page
yeah on that list so it was not in the
top no yeah four pages of requested see
their voting hi Bob finds environment
right yeah they got time on their hands
they're not flying advanced warfare
gross um yeah I think it's just one of
those things like if it's technically
feasible they should just do it yeah and
and I actually think it's kind of cool
like you see stuff like you know and
maybe you'll see more of this like the
idea of the the old game as pre-order
bonus rights or something like that
where like you know if you get fallout 4
on the Xbox one you don't give you
fallout 3 and you know that that will
almost obviously definitely be that 360
version yeah not gonna do any custom
work there and then was a rainbow six
vegas comes with e something yeah one
and two I think yeah both of them comes
with CJ would see ya so I think that's
like a cool idea like they've got all
this stuff laying around yeah that you
know maybe people haven't played and you
know why not just get it out there in
different capacities and so I actually
they're selling burnout paradise on 360
as a download right now for three
dollars and seventy four cents really so
I anticipating that this deal might
eventually get done and the burnout
paradise might be playable even though
I've got it on disk somewhere like you
know what screw it like I just wanted to
show up in my game list straightaway so
I went ahead and bought that that
version of the game too yeah anything
that you know and it's it's not going to
be every publisher that's in the
situation where like oh they might take
the server's down because EA were the
only people that were jerks enough to
like work that into their deals yeah
where they could disable the servers for
their games and now it's just like every
a game is Dethklok yeah my chrome hounds
servers down I can't play chrome strip
yeah they were happy I'm full of other
games I definitely thought of that
alright so we won't see chrome paint on
the the most dire for this yeah sure
yeah that's killer well in the meantime
I guess Gobert go by Burnett paradise
point it's it was that include big surf
island uh I don't think that includes
the dlc it's what everybody got some
version
I'll get you on big surf are many
dollars now I think about shaders I
don't know how much was but yeah you
know you go buy the fake DeLorean Back
to the Future car all great other stuff
they sold for that thing to get your
motor bikes yeah I'll happen you know
you don't need the dlc for you don't
need the bikes that's a big surf island
you don't mixer filings not that great i
know like this it should have been yeah
anyway you don't be anyway there you go
right there burnett revenge burkburnett
crash even getting some votes there look
at that yeah that's a bit deck well get
more in log in you leave a comment say
big surf island as well yeah so go ahead
vote yourself on xbox feedback there if
you bought me an ax 0 for failing to
happen no don't start that Konami Hudson
whoever owns that stuff these days
50,000 to only 47 742 more bomberman act
0 things votes to make our reality Jeff
thanks so much for coming on hey huh
peter brian hi are you sticking around
I'm cigarette maker the whole show man
you Jesus Christ sorry bad smell I stick
around I'll be back in a second to talk
about final fantasy seven if that remake
is a good idea but first of all let's
check out some predator in mortal kombat
cuz [ __ ] you why not
predator wins fatality just a little off
the top
I liked me before he blows the other but
not the head the land of the draft like
that whoa well see ya oh all right so
that happened okay okay thank you Steve
thank you for that that was good that's
good that's bull as my favorite one no
no I was ok to do another pair of mouth
yeah
oh hi Internet do you like video games
do you like Japanese role-playing games
have you been asking for a HD we release
of final fantasy 7 of course you have
that's all we've heard on gamespot com
for the past but a final fantasy 7 come
at nine ninety-two seven seven yeah a
year before the big one year before 98
Jeremy Janie peter brian you guys played
final funny 7 back in the day and we
finally gosh i remember back at the
PlayStation experience we got like yeah
we're gonna rerelease final fantasy 7
but looks exact same and everyone was
super not happy about that yeah but this
year t3 they showed a trailer with some
CG ass Cloud Strife happening they're
remaking fine 57 yes hey art yeah I'm an
HD thing they're just gonna go whole hog
on this yeah which could mean a lot of
different things right i mean a Alexa
talked to I think tats you know more of
the director at e3 and he was saying
like yeah the story you know that story
already exists why would we want to put
the same story out there it's going to
change loss yeah yeah but well I mean
think about it this way so a lot of
people got upset when they announced
this they're like you know we want our
game to be untouched it's this canonical
piece of gaming history and we want it
you know to look beautiful and to be
touched up but essentially to be an
untouched game but from where I'm
standing it's kind of like why would you
want to play like I played that game
several times I shouldn't even ask
question why which won't play the same
game again but like don't you like if
they're gonna bring in all these
beautiful creative people to like work
on this amazing project wouldn't want
them to put new things in it and like we
imagine it without corrupting the like
central core of final fantasy 7 I don't
know man i'm not a big fan finest you
found but if I think of like an HD
remake of any of my like big and
nostalgia pull a game yes don't [ __ ] my
old game for sure that's where my brain
goes straight away so i don't know like
that you can still go back and play a
final fantasy 7 the remake will never
negate the existence right original so
you will always have that to go back to
what i am excited about is seeing stuff
like this right we're looking at Midgar
here which are the slums of Midgar I
think it's sector 7 or sector nine and
and you know these is sort of back in
the day when you played this game you
got a real sense of the identity of the
environment the people who live there is
because of the pretty good storytelling
you know
the dialogue was really campy but you
really got to know the environment and
the society and those are the things I'm
interested in seeing like you know
elevated to new levels with greater
attention to detail just you know better
framing and composition before there
were fixed cameras for the most part
yeah text bubbles for everything yes Lee
so yeah I mean I mean I'm nervous as
hell about hearing you know I guess you
could have heard Cloud Strife voice if
you watch advent children hmm you know
the movie they made but I sure did chef
I was pretty that's really all it was
yeah and people are worried that they're
going to be like elements from that you
know incorporated into seven and seven
was so popular that you know advent
children and some of the other games
that even came after it really
springboard it off at success but never
really stayed true to like the core that
made a falcon stuff so special it
exploited that game and that's and that
the identity of all the characters to
come up with new stuff so the guys I
just hope it doesn't do that isn't just
a reality of one of these games that if
you remake a game like this like going
back and playing that game and seeing
like how much detail as in each area and
how quickly the plot moves from like
place to place to place like if you
frame that game in a fully realized CG
world it just kind of wouldn't work like
it would just feel really strange like
the area that you play in in that in
that town you're in earlier way buddy
might seem really like it's like if you
had like are you saying like if you had
the original resident evil but Yuri made
it in the Risen evil four engine you'd
be like walking around those
environments but you wouldn't have those
like fixed camera thinking where the
hell do we make the edge war is
inevitable but that would work as
exceptional I feel like that would work
because it's such a small area I'm
saying is like when they made these
games in the past they only had the
ability to run every small thing but
they kind of obfuscated 'add they made
you think that was part of a real world
right whereas the way we make things
feel like real worlds today as we make
make a real world for sure so well I
mean that's that's why this is an
exciting opportunity at least in my
opinion cuz like i love final fantasy
seven man i play that game like when it
came out and I was a kid and like I
struggle through my computer couldn't
run it i would like to lose my save data
all the time but like that game was so
worth it because it was it was such an
insane narrative experience that it's
like reading a book like my brain filled
in so much of that game because that
game didn't fill in a lot of things for
you because it's you know it's an older
game they like
today the fixed camera angles there were
things that I wondered about and like
why can't I go over there and see what's
over there I'm excited to see you know
all of these people who are so excited
and passionate about this project create
those like missing spots and then go
back and fill in and flesh out the world
a little more there's the danger though
them actually having the time in the
budget to do that or because if you look
at something like final fantasy 13 like
yeah you know that's a big budget final
fantasy game that they were working on
it for a very long time and you look at
the sort of locales that are there yeah
they're pretty sparse like there's a
couple NPCs it doesn't feel like a
living environment the way I think so
much of final fantasy 7 did right but
also that game that world is huge like
there are you know when you end up
playing 7080 hours into that game you
end up in little villages you know like
forest on the middle of nowhere they
have these little pockets of like hidden
areas it's it's hard for me to imagine
how that structure is going to work for
something like a modern Final Fantasy
game with the way that they design it
these days because the last few have
been linear as hell they haven't made
like a large open map Final Fantasy game
in such a long time apart from 14 but
that doesn't really count so for
something like final fantasy 7 we just
saw some footage there and there's some
footage of some X Games blah blah we
just got some footage of the the one
they showed off the PlayStation
experience is sort of the idea of HD up
the old game but if they're making this
new game in a new engine in the world
like what does that mean in terms of new
content you just like add a couple of
more mini games to go saw so do you add
like entire new parts of the world's do
you have to change the story to enable
that I don't think they need to to add
to it very much apart from the world
building aspect of it I don't think
there needs to be more content because
you play that game in a 70 80 our game
that's that's quite a bit of content
already I mean one thing they could do
depending on how they manage the the new
combat because it probably will horse I
doubt it'll be turn-based it could be
but the materia system made the game so
interesting right and how you could have
one bit of materia and raise it over the
course of dozens of hours to finally
unlock some crazy things so you combine
that with other things you've had a
similar adventure with and to even add a
couple new material make that
interesting I think would be enough for
a lot of people to get really excited
about playing it again that's going to
be an interesting thing when they when
they go
whatever they do to the combat Jeremy
are you in favor of them changing it up
or would you want to play classic like
for Phoenix tan for 50 seconds or I I
recent the final fantasy nine is one of
the only ones that I didn't play it out
it's like the golden age or whatever the
hell and Alexa was like you have to go
play it so that was like my homework so
I went home and I start playing that
game and I really liked it and I got
pretty far into it but I have to say
that the like old like active time
comment like filling the meters and
stuff like it worked so great for me
back in the day and there's just
something like I just don't have time
for that or like something or like work
and you won't see or it feels like
antiquated but like God if the one thing
they have to fix is the summit
animations cuz like anyone who's played
final fantasy 7 you like seven nights of
the round then you go like microwave a
burrito cuz it's gonna be like that in
it until you're doing anything again so
like I mean they have to do something
with a combat I just I don't know how
it's gonna play out because I think it
has to be turn-based like I but I don't
know how it's gonna be you would think
so I mean Final Fantasy 15 that game
initially it lets you control multiple
party members now they've whittle it
down to one because that's just that's
essentially what you have to do when
you're doing real-time combat like this
with a party your party's just there to
support you and I think the combat in
the game overall will absolutely suffer
if you do not have control over your
entire team and doing that as a single
player you might yeah you might need
that active Time battle or turn-based
combat you know system that we're used
to you know do you how would you feel
about them adding all this stuff to the
game and then just having like some
weird ass classic mode that you hit just
like lets you do all the old stuff I
would love that yeah it's not a bad idea
at all yeah I mean I I'm very worried
about this remake but I'm very excited
that they're actually they have the
balls to give it a shot right me I mean
that's why I'm excited because like sure
there's the risk of them [ __ ] it up
in this just being like some snafu in
gaming history and everyone is so pissed
but like if they don't take that risk
they don't have the opportunity to
potentially make something words like oh
whoa like if I tell my kids to play
final fantasy 7 i'm gonna be like play
this one I mean like that may not be I
feel like that won't be the case but I
really hope it is you never know yeah
last question for both you guys I'm
gonna put you on the spot Jeremy when
will we see this remake of Final Fantasy
said Oh God ah good
year and quarter but when Atlantis rises
from the sea I have no idea got a quote
you gotta get one I'm gonna go back
we're gonna go back in the in the in the
b-roll we're gonna back in the archive
sorry for this in a couple years oh
maybe at a couple of months kyu won
20-17 I have no idea okay that's
ambitious q3 2019 oh [ __ ] really yeah q3
2019 yeah okay I mean [ __ ] look how long
has taken him to make the other final
fantasy games right all right we'll see
we'll see you for all still around then
I'll be dead yeah your problem I
probably you live a very entertaining
rich life you'll probably gonna razor's
edge man's gotta catch up with your man
yeah we'll be back in a second we're
more hot video game conversations about
all the stuff that's coming up in 2015
but first of all they've put it on I
don't know what the hell's going on with
this game this game is so good we played
it a blizzcon overwatch but they have
put out like 30 million different
character trailers for it I feel like
they're doing it a disservice yep but
anyway check out the latest character
trainer for this really great game it's
been really badly marketed you should
silver watch
you
we're all soldiers now
kill
hey whats up its 2015 turns out it's a
pretty great year for video games six
months in we had some great video games
this year blood-borne the witcher 3 wild
hunt you pick one Rob handlery you said
which her I sure did um Peter Brant well
soon stitute it's pretty great you
kidding me is all we're gonna come up
with all I've been playing is what
you're right you're just looking at
forward is that it I've been playing you
just looking for Gillian yeah oh yeah oh
my god there's so much better games
coming at this year have Co already
comment this year I can't believe this
is me looking through Wikipedia because
I can't think of any off the top of my
head I they're dying light was all right
there it is oh that's pretty great day
enjoy that okay touch my boot sorry yeah
stop touching your beard and making too
much noise will edit this part out don't
worry yeah you gotta get it holding at
pizza ergo Batman Arkham Knight Maggie a
walk Mortal Kombat X evolved was okay
okay dying light look all right the
order 1886 rainy goggle really is it was
gonna do all right case in point this
year's moving pretty good for you the
witcher 3 is pretty good but the rest of
you here looks even better dude looks
even better between now I the time we
celebrate that little Nazareth II and
baby thing it's gonna be Fitz it's off
the chain I don't get a hold of all this
the games uh they're coming at that we
can be excited for good because they're
in alphabetical order please no [ __ ]
star in chronological order starting all
your third with rare replay yes I'm
common rare games going back banjo
kazooie and viva pinata and so on
perfect dark no Goldeneye but you know
the rest of us you excited for that a no
nurse perfect dark I absolutely loved
that was like the nice segue out of gold
and i right like mmm this is golden I
just a little more futuristic pro-am Xin
it Conker's Bad Fur Day there's a lot of
good stuff in the
8-bit era as well which has some of the
best music out of rare I'm stoked about
that actually fun august 3rd to get you
warmed up to a crazy August in September
volumes at August eighteenth Mike
Bithell second game then we've got gears
of war Ultimate Edition on august twenty
fifth and on that same thing we've
madden 16 and until dawn any hot takers
for until dawn I played that a couple of
times no love it no just can't wait to
play more it's okay it's got a hayden
penitent troop it Padilla's Hayden
Hayden pity player potentially a pay
pedo pedo Tron Hayden pay the Tron and
that's gonna be interesting to read the
reviews of that one cuz it could go
either way I'm looking forward to it as
she is she's scared that's like trying
to go for just like a CD me i like it is
going all the way with like it's like
night trap but 2015 [ __ ] and
moving swiftly on the next week once
you're finished playing on till dawn and
metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain yeah
you pretty psyched about that yeah I'm
pretty psyched about it hopefully a lot
of that game already and it can't not
come soon enough soon enough tell us
things bed the game you're not let's say
I kind of wish I could you play as a
child soldier no although the only
reason I'm buying the game I can't I
can't talk about Johnson Tina you can
you know I talk about psychologist and
it takes about my eggs or by agile your
head no def of eggs are is the revenge
in it yes revenge is the central plot of
the game revengeance whoa there's so
many things I want to talk about this is
actually like kind of painful really I'm
sorry is it the killing me we're all
excited about it there's Afghanistan
never look so beautiful real time with
her OD [ __ ] that's what's not very real
good that was the best porn add the same
day that's coming out September first
bad max is coming out yeah that was a
badly timed yes situation here I mean
who knows we but it looks I was
surprised by like when the last gameplay
trailers they had you know they showed
off some cool stuff like you no soup up
your car and hit the desert Oh your
magnum opus yeah yeah I'm talking about
fixing up here look it's exactly the
same you and zeros yes if you've got a
magnum opus instead of a poor some Chum
Bucket writing
bag that's his name Chum Bucket Chum
Bucket straight up yes to muck it right
up you when you see the nighttime scenes
you'll know why he's called Chum Bucket
hey I wonder if this has got real time
weather real-time Chum Bucket go can't
wait for that Avalanche Studios got two
games coming out this year we'll talk
about the second one later at September
11 Super Mario maker hidden the wii u
one of the only big wii u games coming
as hell yeah looking forward today i am
there's a huge community of people that
mod the original super mario world and
they have made crazy [ __ ] over the past
like 10-15 years and to actually have
official tools and ways to share that
stuff online it's gonna be great I think
the e3 stuff really sold me on that I
didn't really care about it before but
the Nintendo World Championships were
we're pretty fun we're watching the
stream in the games about a war room
that was odd that was all right and
moving swiftly on September 15th we got
forza motorsport 6 mighty number 9 and
again I know you guys are really excited
about pro evolution soccer 2016 damn
right mighty number 9 Peter I know
you're a big fan yeah I'm I've played a
little bit of it when it was like sort
of like the early beta stuff and it was
good but but I felt like crap it's not
different enough from megaman that I'm
going to be really amped to finish it so
I want to see what they've done in the
meantime I know they've added new levels
and such but I want this guy there's
something missing there's an element of
it that wasn't there so I'm curious to
see it yes it'll be good to see if I'm
finally fully playable after the the
Kickstarter love us a lot think it was
only last year I think it's been oh it's
been a while you're in 82 years eyes are
really yeah two years yeah it'll be
interesting to finally see that they're
one of the sort of early kick star or
sort of second wave kick star successes
moving on September 20th Skylanders
supercharged said 22nd FIFA 16 and tony
hawk pro skater 5 is at September 25th
is it really gonna come out that time
yeah it's kind of crazy I'd like I don't
know we haven't seen anything have we so
there was a bit of gameplay they showed
on Geoff Keighley stage at e3 but like
no I'm bad at my job very little bit
like it was it was bad two minutes of
your old sort of feels too bad and it
kind of looks very much like the HD
re-release of there too they did or I
guess just HD
them or whatever and so I guess we'll
see it looks like an arcade game so I'm
not still not sure how much if there's
some stuff look at that look at him I
love the framerate mom yeah there was
this was the there was a bit of frame 80
problems apparently with this with this
footage yeah i got my boards on fire
ripping it up i just watched that weird
movie about the australian skateboarders
last night i would so my look at that
guy hey do a manual do a manual I hope
they have a kickflip competition that
video in this one as well they was
already pretty pretty sick back in the
day September 29th NBA 2k16 I always
find a weird they released and then like
kind of when the season's over like
before it starts again I feel like it's
a real safe like holiday gift for
parents to get kids right right so like
violent shooter almost sports that's a
future next year already okay Billy off
the couch inspire him and some time in
September we're gonna get a drift as
well there's no date on not yet but
that's all we know so far did either you
guys paid a drifted III yeah interesting
a little bit okay that moving on october
six rock band 4 mmm their lack yeah
guitars and [ __ ] or if it's rock band
you're talking about then all of them
drums and everything we've got a room
full of drugs there's no Chester to
scale it look at him I got I'm
unbelievable I wonder how often people
think Nick is cliffy because they do
have that sort of still a little grin on
their face I feel like if he's always
got a chainsaw in his hand instead of a
guitar though rockbound for from
harmonix you guys interested in this or
guitar hero live I'm interested in
watching other people have fun with it i
yes suck at these games I didn't really
have much fun playing but of these game
I like watching people get into it yeah
I got into like guitar hero with like
when it was popular in like with me for
in college oh yeah totally total blast
cuz it was easy to put on and play and
was blast it blasted black tunes hot
vids get blasted no I mean totally bra
I'm so I the minute they announced that
I was coming out I was like [ __ ] I live
on like a second-floor apartment now oh
yeah for so I like put that in to make
extra yeah because I was all about that
what
shut up up there were two kids yeah
we'll see October ninth uncharted the
nathan drake collection HD re-releases
still common 2015 octobre 13 Tom
Clancy's Rainbow six siege you played a
bit of this rom right we did yeah alpha
um I think they're coming back soon with
an with another one slay a lot of office
invaders for this it was flying I think
it started off with a great I mean it's
just you know such a team centric game
yeah that's what's really great in the
office was you get to like kind of
collaborate but a couple times I played
solo I remember at grenades alpha all
speculation but I remember a couple
times was like all right this is getting
a little repetitive yeah I needed none
that a kick some kind of like motivation
I mean again it's just like you know
they only show off like one map too much
yeah Lorelei's but it's interesting
because it's the same sort of thing
we're like I know like loads of people
the office played evolved back in the
day like earlier this year actually and
that was you know super fun for all you
guys came out it just didn't like catch
on like nobody was playing it out I saw
Chris waters playing last week I was
shocked oh really he still thinks I'm
fall yes yes Oh time fo I got seem
played I yeah yeah moving on guitar here
alive October 20th hot on the heels on
van rock band 4 actually I skipped one
Yoshi's woolly world yeah exactly I just
want the amoeba [ __ ] hell [ __ ] God
look I spent a hundred work 30 bucks in
that stupid pitboy ding ah-me Bo's got
down october twenty third Assassin's
Creed syndicate it's another set it's
another sins creed grapple and and GTA
like racing on carts and stuff yep just
like GTA drive-bys in Victorian London
or post-industrial London I'm i love
this series so much i like some of the
old games are like best favorite games
of the the last generation of consoles
I'm just I don't know what it is I I
think if I even saw a really good
Assassin's Creed game I'd be buzzed for
but something about this one even in
particular it's just like knock grab a
meal I am so tired of hoods and cloaks
and leaping and climbing and contextual
controls just [ __ ] end it down from
marriage
super kid it's a it's gonna be
interesting i'm sure to a lot of sauces
screen phones to let their but yeah like
I feel like your guy sentiments are when
you ask just general people about this
that nobody is really getting excited
about anymore it'll be interesting to
see if they just give this this is all I
want just running over see aliens you
shake get going I'm an assassin I'm
doing it for some sort of greater good
but you Oh God darn it my lamp post and
the next week or actually that same week
I think within four days October 27th
halo 5 yeah why dians yeah excited by
that I'm speaking my language yeah
you're a big halo fan you excitement got
a huge halo fan always have been I've
bought an xbox like four times probably
my life for that halo of course pausing
before I got Moxie but an xbox for every
single halo yes and then twice more
dedicated and then twice wonder I got
the red ring oh yeah 360 but anyways um
last year was are obviously the worst
year to be a halo fan when Master Chief
collection so this is like I'm so
excited because as far as I play the new
game mode war zone is such a refresh
from like four which is toliet it was
fun but I got tiresome when it was like
all right stop trying to milk a call
duty ask no yeah pear drops or excuse me
ordinance drops and all that stuff here
you have war zone which is like
battlefield esque yeah like it's chaotic
and it was real like I played like two
rounds but you could see it being really
fun you know and then you hear they're
also just making a lot of great moves um
except for one which is the no longer
can you split screen co-op Oh [ __ ]
really yeah that's a big letdown cuz
I've done that every year but sarcasm
that's a shame there's a little bit of
chance for some people but um you hear
stuff like you know no future DLC maps
will be um paid for yeah that's all free
I'm not like they're just making cool
moves and I like I'm sure they'll have
their own DLC a time for but like I
don't been getting on Destiny's our slaw
recently but I like they're just seems
whenever halo comes out halo is a game
that has just so much so many modes in
it yeah like that I remember ones 3k
matt and had a lot Ford stuff and a
multiplayer and then I'll go
I'm pain like you always feel like
you've gotten your sort of money's worth
at a halo and I'm not a huge fan but
yeah the war zone stuff looks looks
interesting really weird for me it's non
sequitur real quick anytime I halo game
comes out keep it like a month that game
is half price yeah that is one of the
biggest Triple A games to drop its price
tag out of any other series that I know
I think it must be because Microsoft
have like coin and that I wonder if it's
like a loss leader for them selling the
kosher know exactly yeah but it just it
plots so fast dozen meters of war yeah
yeah but like when for came out it took
like a few weeks for to be down in like
40 bucks yeah oh so hold on your cash
kids here's that use I use the Christmas
money at WWE 2k16 also at that day good
show if you sir Stone Cold's on the box
man Big Show's on the wrestler I know
when we interviewed him last year at
Gamescom yeah we maybe we'll do it again
this year to see at November third need
for speed is ash I think I know is that
that day as well the latest one and
november six call of duty black ops 3
yeah blops i play a bunch of times
actually oh yes you know i posted an
advanced warfare which in beginning i
was like oh this is great you know the
old all this you know crazy mobility
stuff and then you get black ops and
it's it's not as messed out okay you're
just like people are just totally it's
like all right let's let's ground the
shooter again that's what halos doing
perfectly again its or their early
staffing it too it's like all right you
get one boost and that slow recharge
yeah they're doing the same thing with
black ops you know slow movement the
clam brings great and that there's also
that total overwatch you know power
player just kind of modes where it's
like yeah you know there's like cool
moves were the one my favorite is a
glitch which was this move we're like
you know you you basically work
backwards like five seconds kind of like
that yet I like the lady and overwatch
but Tracy tracer yeah and it's
interesting cuz i played a preview of
this give of glitch and I remember
telling the devs like dude like I own
this down it's so terrifying cuz that in
the beginning like when I first saw it
it was just the guy would just disappear
immediately yeah you wouldn't no idea
where he was so you need screwed cuz I
now if i use it i know you are now they
have a little bit of the trace
gentleman you can kind of get an
adjustable direction yeah direction um
so I like it's going good I mean it's
you know again live call duty games i'll
play for a period of time yeah and I
feel like black ops is the one that the
online community for two is still so
high that they kind of need to pull I
feel like this is them dragging people
kicking and screaming from the xbox 360
over to ya over text box when or ps3 to
ps4 and moving on though November 10th
what a banger rise of the tomb Raider's
ash so it's fun I've got down for you
guys I'm so excited about this I've been
playing that stupid I got 109 people and
my stupid iOS vault thing oh man I've
been playing that a lot too yeah but
this is just I cannot wait like what a
treat for them to show the game off it
of the show off all the stuff they've
added to it this terrifying constants or
your wife or husband is looking over
your shoulder and then for it to be
coming at like three months later like
we're almost there almost there already
it's gonna be such a time sucker for me
I love like I watched you know I think
it didn't get chance to watch it live
cuz we were you know frantically cutting
these up hmm um but I remember watching
you again and being so blown away about
that one line where he said uh when the
the kind of Jarvis esque robot says your
name he's like we've pre-loaded a
thousand common names yeah you know say
your names you type it in like that just
a small small little clicks like that
yeah it ever really are going organic
port is gonna work like you know bar
like my own son my child is also named
bort I wonder if you'll find board
license plates around the waist hey yeah
it's it's a fully voiced as well so
goddammit maybe we'll get our first two
discs gain no actually we're one cuz
you're just downloaded oh I got the
collectors man yeah oh really I bought
it at me too we're gonna look like dorks
on our second street experiences and the
next week november seventeenth star wars
battlefront i'm not really a big star
Wars fan I do like battlefield but I
fallen off the past couple years but god
dammit this link game looks absolutely
crazy cool looking so if there's one
thing you could toll cuz I got to play
this it was I last time I was on his
couch I didn't like it cuz I feel like
gameplay video and yeah they kind of
didn't show much when you guys so right
and then I played it and there are just
certain things that you can file away
into a
cabinet and be like this is going to be
great it's gonna look awesome it's gonna
sound awesome it is a star wars game I
that's where I really got like it feels
like Star Wars he felt like it um I
gotta [ __ ] it was really funny I had a
couple of gripes and I think of deaths
of spoken already on it which were like
the flying hmm is is really Jenky um I
will be playing this on PC just because
I'm a huge flight nerd so I'll just like
have my joystick I will be compatible
but the controls of that were I crashed
so often couldn't get a kill off I've
Vlad welcome buddy blames his tools man
yeah but in in general um it was really
fun I enjoyed it I think yeah they do a
great job of showing elected with the
Caspian Border stuff with battlefield 3
and Althea force gameplay they do a
great job of showcasing this it'll be as
with any game that has this many types
of vehicles it's gonna be really
interesting to see if they can balance
it out but man it looks pro tip you
can't take down a TIE fighter with a
pistol god I can keep trying man you
never know it'll be like Battlefield 4
you'll just they'd couches in that game
you can shoot from and stuff no world
the world did they have the bear fat
yeah there's no social moon god Amun and
later nine months 26th just in case you
didn't have enough hot bangers
TrackMania turbo coming out yeah console
track Manny no just me okay and also
november and XCOM 2 we don't know when
yet but XCOM 2 is gonna come any any
fans of the old ex con games or the
earth so much you're right now I didn't
love them they're good gains I don't
have a personal tent I love them I loved
all the old ones I love Tara from deep
UFO defense or and all those there's a
couple of dodgy third-person ones in the
middle but yeah when they when they
remade and I thought that was like one
of the best remakes in recent memory I
was a jagged alliance guy back oh really
oh yeah and no jagged lines coming up
this year sorry Peter bran and December
just when you think all the video games
are out there's a couple of little more
dribbles out of the video game facio
December first talk about that Chum
Bucket just calls three Avalanche got
something left in the tank Just Cause 3
yes surprising i played one play a
little bit of two um not huge fans this
one of things works like right rather be
playing
GTA sometimes I get that one swell but I
actually played three for a while oh
yeah with the debug menu in it and holy
[ __ ] is that game fun when you can just
like I'm gonna spawn anywhere in the
world I'm gonna spawn all these weapons
I'm gonna stand all this and that like
and the wingsuit it now like you can
it's just amazing like you can grapple
to a thing flick yourself off of they go
into the air and and pretty much like
Neverland if you're really good mm-hmm I
just execute like spider mounting your
way through the road yeah yeah no I mean
and your you know your throne you just
you can just do all these crazy things
like oh well that's what sold me was
like Victor when he we started doing the
combo of the grapple moves that was what
really took me away I was like how he
was doing all those cool things he says
it's been a while since we've seen Rico
Rodriguez on this looks this looks like
super this you know what this is the
perfect December game this is the
perfect I've got some time off for the
holidays yeah I'm just gonna sit at home
on my ass eat like turkey and and drink
beer and just play a dumb game that I
don't really have to think about very
often hey here's a girl [ __ ] it's not
too gonna do here hit the button Rico we
only only one sure yep it's gonna land
this thing and make it explode maybe no
just go straight at December first at
december for zen ably Chronicles X is
out and then December eighth last big
release of the year it's not really a
full release but it's coming out there's
the explosion there you go look at that
boom boom boom hey doesn't stop keeps on
going premium December eighth hit man's
back age of 47 they're releasing this
game we're like a bunch of missions in
it it's not like the hell it's a
full-price game like I don't know how
many but that's it for the sake of
argument say quarter half the missions
they're gonna be releasing the missions
later in here some sort of weird early
access type scenario and you guys hit
man fans they release this straight or
easier I can't think of a more generic
ass character really i gets i have such
a softie like i'm a big fan of the old
get like i've played them all okay maybe
not the the camera before last but big
fan of him i wanted to blood money is
absolutely spectacular but yeah it's
just something about the Tobias Reaper
character the agent 47 Gargery sort of
doesn't really play anymore
exciting at all it's so boring to look
at that guy that game is fun like the
game on the little sandbox is to like
murder folks if I'm gonna get hooked
into a series that's existed for so long
you know and sort of like sticks with
the same thing like I needed there to be
something different to grab me and
usually that's like a character right or
a setting this is just the same
character the same settings like if
Assassin's Creed was Altai year for
these past 12 games like where we've
been after a while no I was just that's
what it's saying before it ever gets
fair freakin assassin has a hood and a
cloak and dagger and it shut up maybe
it's a different age and every time just
all got alopecia yeah I guess we'll find
out later in the air and before I let
you guys go what is the game you're most
looking forward to in 2015 Rob first of
all it's halo yeah okay yeah I just want
it it's one of stinks two words like man
if this doesn't go as well as I hope
it's gonna be like bummer I'm out you
got some other games look forward to
though if it doesn't work out yeah Peter
what about yourself it's all metal gear
oh yeah yeah sorry I keep hitting my leg
production crew no one will be a beard a
bit more Yeah right kids love that ah
yeah no metal gear is going to be such a
a massive game it is you know the
missing chapter and the entire like
storyline of metal gear solid and the
original Metal Gear and I'm just I'm
ready to see how they tied all together
yeah and it's less than two months away
yeah freaking out cuz it's like a
hundred our game and I'm doing the
review so great yeah we wanted to be
like Kevin with the witcher you'll just
have to stay home probably attack i'll
be at PAX Prime in the hotel for really
i don't know we'll see you i don't know
how we're gonna get the game or not and
my game i'm probably looking forward to
more than all of them is fallout 4 it's
a turns out this year is pretty great
for video games there's any game that we
failed to mention all right again they
came in earlier this year that you're
looking forward to or if one of the
games we talked about just now tickles
your fancy let us know what you think is
the best game comment 2015 in the
comments below video games it's pretty
good year for games thanks very much
everyone for watching the show thanks to
rob and Peter and all of our guests on
today's show thanks to everyone in the
production crew for putting off for
Peters beard scratching leg topping
[ __ ] seasick Steve kind of routine
they got going here and marry josh act a
tomahawk ty route may be back there as
well
I smell his Cologne oh my god here we go
the board board board come here bored
sorry no my son is also named Boris
classic and we're done because we're
probably getting pulled off of youtube
and twitch right now we can do better
[ __ ] one in our livestream though so
if you're watching there hey all right
we'll see you guys next week go for it
you